my motto in life is first say yes then
freak out
and then make it work say yes freak out
make it work i'll dub that i'll take it
so that's me i freaked out and we're
making it work and we already have
500 surges on our database 5 000 egg
donors and over 40 fertility providers
which makes us pretty much the biggest
large the largest database in the world
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of make-a-wish israel and tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret core adventures j ventures
riverside fm
fusion vc
birthright excel
j impact
leap
google for startups and hippo and in
media partnership with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders here at
google for startups i'm really excited
to be talking about a really
big part of society family building and
family creation and i'm really honored
to be hosting ronnie from expecting
talking to us about how
expecting.ai is doing exactly that
harani is the co-founder and cmo of
expecting ai a full stack marketer with
15 years of experience in marketing
brand building and chief revenue officer
in enterprise and startup environments
spanning across various industries such
as online marketplaces automotive retail
and more
ronnie leads brand and product strategy
and seeks to combine traditional
marketing concepts alongside generating
a transformation and customer engagement
achieved with data-driven marketing
methods
ronnie has a master's degree in
communication and management from tel
aviv university started her career in
adler kromsky in gray one of israel's
largest advertising agencies managing
global accounts and then switched to the
client side as the head of marketing for
switch the online marketplace startup by
call mobile corp
following her startup experience ronnie
led youndai's marketing in israel where
she initiated a digital transformation
across the distribution chain
transforming the brand to a data-driven
operation
[Music]
ronnie welcome to 20 minute leaders
thank you so much for being here thank
you so much for having me i'm i'm really
excited because you're working on one of
the most interesting problems that we
have in the world today you know
generations are shifting perceptions are
different families are different the way
we look we perceive families we perceive
relationships and it's really quite
remarkable what's happening and we're in
2022 and you're the co-founder and chief
marketing officer of expecting ai and so
thank you very much for being here hi
thank you for having me um yeah we will
address the issues about
one one in eight people in america are
suffering from infertility one in six in
the world one in four in china this has
become a global pandemic and the numbers
are growing yearly so yeah we have a lot
to speak about i i hope you have time
for me
well
how many one and how many in the world
one in six in the world one in six in
the world that's about 18
of the world one two three four five six
close your eyes imagine your friends one
of them is fighting infertility um
they can be you know
um
due to a
health issue or
other stuff but from the beginning
no worries okay yeah um
so yes one in six in the world are
suffering and fighting infertility and
we are here to help them um
also you can add to that the gay
community
in the past 10 years
it's more likely that they will want to
have children as well
and you have celebrities like kim
kardashian that is bringing a lot of
awareness to the fact that surrogacy is
out there and it's an option um so we
have
many many many internet parents in the
world that will turn to surrogacy egg
donations sperm donation
ivf treatments
so does there are a lot of people that
needs to go through this roller coaster
um journey and most of them don't even
know where to start wow they have a
million questions in mind so basically
expecting that ai is the one single
place where they can come and start
their journey uh in one single place
and when they have all these questions
and when they have to find a surrogate
egg donor
agency fertility clinics
mental health professional insurance it
goes on and on and it's overwhelming so
now there's one single place where they
can come and easily easily connect and
start their journey in more seamless
experience so i want to understand the
the overwhelming portion of it just a
little bit because
you know
i i didn't know that it's one and six
have infertility and and you would
assume that this you know we hear a lot
of statistics all day long
but no one speaks about it i mean why so
why is it such a lonely
problem i think that
one of the best parts in my job the
reason that i wake up with a huge smile
on my face every day is that i really
get to build families and i get to speak
to people that feel
very very lonely right sometimes they
don't even share it with their mother or
their best friend because think about a
regular pregnancy we won't even tell
anyone until you know 12 weeks at least
not to jinx it knock on wood
um
so when it comes to this complex and
costly and long journey
they don't want to disappoint anyone and
they don't want to share it with anyone
and then we get a lot of times we get
sentences like so what are you there
you're just you know our angels you're
just gonna hold my hand and when i'm
crying in bed in bed and i'm like yes
this this is why i'm here
our company does not charge any fees
from intended parents um
we're here to help and i think that this
is something that personally i felt is
missing in every single thing that i
did until now wow yeah because i was a
marketeer i was born a marketeer
probably
i knew ads by heart when i was four
years old nobody could listen to me
saying you know
clementino there's a an ad in hebrew um
so when the moment came and nadav
my co-founder when he talked to me about
what he's working on it clicked
immediately take me back to that moment
okay paint me the picture of one you
really want to know okay it was right
after the birth of my third child and
the exact moment tim robbins was in
israel and i'm like okay now i'm gonna
focus on my family i'm not gonna chase
this career anymore this life is not
balanced i'm gonna stop everything i'm
gonna
head to my family and he said wow it's
wonderful listen you have to check this
out and i'm like i'm going to say no i'm
going to say no i'm going to say no but
my motto in life is first say yes then
freak out
and then make it work say yes freak out
make it work i'll dub that i'll take it
so that's me i freaked out and we're
making it work and we already have
500 surrogates on our database 5 000 egg
donors and over 40 fertility providers
which makes us pretty much the biggest
large the largest database in the world
for a third party production
suppliers or vendors or partners however
you look at them they're my friends all
of them wow the intel and parents i'm
there for them but also we care a lot
about creating value to the surrogates
who are amazing women who put their
bodies out there
and we have these perceptions as you
said that are changing
right now
in order to become a surrogate you have
to be this amazing person who probably
has very very easy
deliveries and you want to help another
family
you're not doing it just for the money
yeah you get compensated for it and
that's okay but it's not just for the
money
and they're going through a screening
process that can take up to six
months just to make sure that they are
the right person for this job because
they're gonna carry somebody else's baby
in their body so they will have home
visits and background check and you know
mental health professionals will speak
to them for a very long time just to
make sure that everything is going right
so first of all yes let's change our
perception these women are amazing
um and we we work very hard to make it
easier for them to start the journey
because they have a million questions as
well they're going through a very long
process as well
and they want to be compensated and to
find the right match so we have the
intended parents we have those women and
we have the agencies
and the agencies
we're doing very very well they've been
operating for like 25 years yeah but
that but then covet hit and suddenly the
sky is closed everything is closed
nothing is working
um and they need to switch to digital
now they're experts in building families
but
they don't have a lot of you know
imagine this jennifer she's been doing
it for 20 years she's amazing
she doesn't even like to work on
powerpoint okay
so this is our place to help them first
of all to go from offline to online
and have this all
process digitalized and also
we're very good listeners and we
realized that after covid
the major pain point for them was to
recruit surrogates because there are any
there's a huge shortage of surrogates so
if you're listening and you're thinking
about becoming a stargate let's speak
because
i want to know if this show made a baby
yeah
that's something that i wanted yeah you
see that's what i want to know every
every morning when i wake up will this
day be over with a baby so so literally
i mean a lot of people have their
mission statements for their companies
your mission statement is to create
families yes we're building families
we're doing everything we have in our
power to give them the reliable
information that they're looking for
to listen to their needs and to solve
every barrier in the way because
basically when you find the right match
at the beginning of your surrogacy
journey
then probably your journey will be
smoother with less hiccups and it will
be shorter and much more cost effective
so we're the matchmakers amazing and so
tell me a little bit about the the
regulatory part of this whole because it
sounds to me like for the last few
decades the way that this has worked is
you mentioning surrogates have to go
through six months of testing and
different home visits to make sure that
they're that they're providing the right
i guess care support both
physiologically and mentally for the
upcoming baby
how how does this fit into a more
digital experience right with expecting
right now what we do um
intelligent parents can come to our
platform they can find the agency that
they want to work with or a specific
surrogate they can book an appointment
and have a zoom call with them
and then we also
give them the option to have another
mental health professional screening
process
privately
on their own terms someone that will
reflect their best interest and have
another revision on the screening
process that has already been done so
that's an option as well
um we also share all the regulation in
each in each state because it changes
from state to state
and right now if we're talking about
legislation then you know there's a huge
drama in the united states
and and it doesn't have a direct effect
although we do know that the red
countries
um
you know internet parents would not want
to go into a surrogacy journey in a
place where they cannot terminate the
pregnancy in case that there's any
concern medical concern for the
surrogate or for the fetus so um right
now if we're speaking about the global
shortage of surrogates now there are
even less options that means the prices
might increase again so we're doing our
best we're taking our tech capabilities
and our marketing capabilities to try
and you know target our campaigns to
recruit surrogates from more liberal
countries so it won't affect um
the shortage of surrogates
what are the motivations for
for surrogates it changes every
surrogate has a different story
but i think
they're complex stories right it's not a
it's not a my story is complex your
story is complex we're all humans we all
carry some bag on our shoulders but yeah
the products are simpler than others and
yeah i mean
it sounds like this is a long journey
besides the besides the money that
that's associated with it's this is a
lengthy process they come to the
surrogacy journey after they
already had at least one child of their
own and it's recommended that they're is
that a must yes it's a must why is that
um
because
it's recommended that you
fi first of all you have to finish with
your building your own family okay so if
something goes south if something
medically will happen
then you won't regret the fact that you
did it it's very very important to keep
the the surrogates safe
so they're making sure
um that she's done building her own
family and then she's ready to move on
and help another family build a family
and most of the times we see that a
surrogate that did it once and it went
okay no no journey goes smoothly but it
went okay we see repeated surges that
are doing it again and again
three times wow so yeah i've spoken with
many many surrogates and they're super
inspiring because they look at it they
say i i don't look to mother the baby
but i some of them will be able to have
a connection with her and have an open
relationship which we didn't used to
have in the past same goes for egg
donation some of the egg donors
actually ninety percent of the egg
donors that
were suggested to have an open
relationship with the intended parents
will actually agree to that and then
imagine that you know her status today
today you know how healthy she he she is
today but within 20 years something may
pop up and you would like to have this
you know medical insurance and know that
you have the ability to to touch base
with her
so
there's a lot going on think about sperm
donation it's the opposite it's a bank
and it's frozen and you have the genetic
test that they already did i can speak
about it for hours that's it it's
incredible yeah now
go back to sort of your your place here
with what you're doing with expecting it
because because you're not just creating
a product you're you're part of a new
you know a new world a new
thinking process for for the way the
families are being built i think that i
was always looking for a place to have
an impact in the world since i was a
little girl okay in the youth groups and
everything
and
when i went working on an ad agency and
later on
for corporates
i was doing my job very very well
with all modesty i was the best
and i was working with market leaders
and the products were selling very very
good and everybody was very very very
happy but at the end of the day i feel
like i'm taking
my marketeer
talents
and i'm not really doing anything with
it
so right now i have the ability to touch
people's heart
to help them with one of the major
decisions in their lives i thought that
you know
buying a car or buying an apartment
might be the hardest decision that a
family needs to make and now
when you realize the customer journey
of bringing a child to the world through
surrogacy and egg donation you realize
how many stops there are in the way how
many question uh
search questions queries how many
pain points in the in in the way that
you need to listen to and find a way to
solve them and what when we do you know
every pro meal step every small step
it's rewarding so this gives me the
drive
to
go straight ahead and being a woman
founder which i just realized it's an
issue
yeah where um
i don't think that i paid enough
attention to it at first i thought hey
i'm ronnie and i'm doing what i'm what i
want to do
but
as this startup is growing i start to
realize that we do have some
responsibility because we have to work
harder than you guys and usually we're
the only women in the room
with many many other men and we need to
prove ourselves or at least we feel like
we need to prove ourselves and now there
might be a woman in the audience that is
listening to us right now and she's
thinking should i do this should i
should i
go for it but i have a family or i don't
have a family and i want to find
the the ability for me to pursue my
dreams
and run for it um
[Music]
it's a lot
but first i say yes
then i freak out and then i make it
happen i i love that mantra
and that's very inspiring i love that
outlook and uh we're certainly you know
peop
talking about creating an equal
opportunity for for men and women
especially when it comes to the sea
level and and founder teams
very far from from from where it needs
to be but we're heading there hopefully
yeah we're heading there i see more and
more of my colleagues you know
breaking the ceiling so
the glass ceiling so hopefully well i
have to say that i uh at least through
the show we've had a
pretty much an equal uh amount of men
and women coming on the show and uh
and and it's it's it's constantly
mind-boggling me you know as a
generation z you know coming into this
coming into this world and coming into
the workforce i i still don't understand
why why right and you and we study in
these history books all these crazy laws
and the and the crazy pro
progress that has been made from from
the from the lack of equality and you
know as a young entrepreneur and a young
thinker i'm constantly thinking to
myself how the hell did they come up
with these weird rules and what happened
to the history of society that has led
to this point because for me and my
friends it's so trivial
that no that there's equality and equal
opportunity and it and it should be this
way and we see tech companies i believe
att just today announced their their
great compensation but but we're running
out something i want to make sure that
that i'm getting to to this question
you know you're you have a a very
significant role within expecting you're
the chief marketing officer in other
words you're responsible for telling the
story
i'm a storyteller yeah that's true and
you're doing it in a way in a place in
an industry that requires a market
education
big time big time i did not know that
one in six people in the world have
problems with fertility
why don't i know that and how are you as
chief marketing officer thinking through
your position to educate the market for
this
i think that it's a very very private
process that each individual is going
through with themselves
and
you will be able to speak about it when
you overcome it
so
our role is to take something that is
certain taboo something that people
don't like to hear about they don't like
to hear about surrogates they don't like
to hear about egg donation sure they
prefer to think that you know babies
come to the world easily but as we grow
up we know that every baby is a miracle
even if you don't need a surrogate or an
egg donation
um
so basically we need to tell the untold
story
if i'll tell you my magic i'll have to
kill you
but i can tell you that it all starts
with listening very very carefully so
we're
we're spending a lot of time on social
media because that's where the
discussion is being held right now so
it's not only paid media and ppc and ltv
and you know no it's listening and it's
just to get the audience where they're
receptive to your message
and telling them what they need to hear
in the exact point so sometimes it's as
simple as listening to their question on
social media and giving them the answer
with the right
link to your blog with the right video
conversation with a mental health
professional with the right link to the
zoom appointment that they can schedule
and then
it starts
from there i mean
30 of our social media leads will end up
you know meeting with an agency wow you
cannot reach that the intent is extreme
because they're already there now
imagine that they have to post a post
about themselves and their history and
what each of the couple is doing and
they have to put it out there and what
if our grandma will see it
i mean this is wrong this is not how it
should be so i have a huge vision about
how it should be and let's speak in a
year and we'll see where i am
but ronnie incredible mission thank you
um challenging uh journey you're not
just building a marketplace you're
you're changing narratives and you're
creating market education
and this past week has shown us how far
away we are with uh with creating the
right narrative uh very unfortunately
but but you know these types of
companies make me hopeful for the future
and inspired and thank you for a lovely
conversation and definitely a topic that
i know too little about and i'm going to
spend some time myself diving into it
because it's it's so ingrained in our
society i had no idea how ingrained and
and so it sounds like it's this is not
just for people who are experiencing
this to dive deep into once they
discover those news but it's as a
society educational tool for us to be
able to understand each other and
provide the right solutions and maybe
part of the problem of what we saw this
past week in the united states is this
lack of market education this lack of
narrative and hopefully expecting will
have a positive impact on on changing a
lot of these things so thank you thank
you so much i had a wonderful time thank
you thank you
[Music]